did you see that documentary what the
kid is still in the picture Kid stays in
the picture stays that's right by Bob
Evans right yeah yeah and uh the dude I
thought you were talking about the
breakfast guy this whole time I swear to
God that character was also in the offer
uh about the making of The Godfather and
the guy who played Amman one of the
characters in The Watchmen was the actor
that played Bob Evans and that he was
[__] great oh oh so I watch it oh
yeah the offer is awesome dude it is so
good oh I got to watch the offer it's on
Paramount plus right uh yeah yeah yeah
that sounded like a by way Bob Evans he
played Aus is that Bob Evans or the the
actor that plays Bob EV the actor the
Bob whoa it looks kind of like Bob Evans
yeah he was great dud dude look at him
that's great that you know who Bob Evans
is I don't this old school Hollywood
executive from Paramount and he green
green lit wow I got to watch it then
that's but also anyone listening right
now watch that documentary the kid stays
in which he narrates himself which is
great imagine that this kid this guy Bob
Evans right yeah was first an actor
didn't wasn't he trying to act he he did
some sort of like movie about he was
elar not El Mar what what the Matador
movie movie uh that I don't know yeah
and then he was a good-looking guy and
he was at a pool and they just turned
into this Hollywood Mogul yeah married
to Ali McGrath oh yeah that's right from
the Love Story yeah which he produced
that movie he produced that movie too
and then produced the then had a
produced The Godfather and had a string
of hits yeah oh my God what a great
document you'll love the offer don't
tell me what I'm going to love man tell
balls on this come in your house tell
them what your no yeah do you watch the
offer no yeah what you don't you sound
like you don't watch I'm not a big movie
guy
tranger you don't you you don't cuz you
didn't watch one thing you you're too
ugly to watch that's what I was you're
cute not say it I did that as a comedy
that's a comedy Kevin have a cup of
coffee please Kevin last night last
night didn't we have our moment we had
our yeah when you tried to send me down
to the Goddamn polter face you try is
that what you were trying to do I was
trying to freak him up a little you
going to S him stairs and turn the
lights out like a [__] bully like a
babysitter he opened the door and
stepped away he was like you go you go
in I'm like get the fu so that's why
you're mad that I didn't come cuz you
didn't get to scare me I know I was
going to scare the [__] out of you you
bastard yeah yeah but when you like I
got news for you I was already scared
just being in the hallway really yeah
yeah why cuz right before we walked in
uh Kim Cogan told noticed that she had a
creepy experience with the the door
opened or something like that she got
shushed she got shushed by like she was
walking by a closet and nobody was in
there and it was like sh oh I didn't
like what Lisa trigger did either what
we were all three walking in the hall
you got upset about that a little bit
we're walk us three were walking in the
hallway and she looks at me she goes out
of the
way love that Le Train I love her and I
I pr and she went beline to you guys
he's like what the [__] is this what she
we had already had a conversation before
that that's why that's her excuse of
course but just I don't like when anyone
does this yeah like out of the way
little man you know what I mean the
whites are coming through I think you're
implying but in my mind that's what it
is you know I mean sure you guys are the
Whites yes wait I have a question for
you um just because I was like a massive
fan girl of this show is it true that
you went to either audition or be part
of Dawson's Creek oh yeah what's that oh
tell tell me Tell man that's a real
positive spin on the real
story you were in Dawson's career